[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi consacré au numérique
et aux innovations pédagogiques tout de
suite le sommaire leader mondial des
générateurs d'eau purifiée mère qu'elle
la boîte heures installa guyancourt
intègre le numérique dans ses
laboratoires dont verrons également
comment il a transformé la politique de
formation de son centre de recherche et
de développement
focus dans ce numéro sur les innovations
pédagogiques développés au sein de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines avec une visite de la
plateforme mirent à patricia bouchon
vice président de l'uwe vs puis en
charge du numérique nous en dira plus
également sur les projets à venir
enfin si vous êtes en recherche d'emploi
ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises de notre
territoire qui recrutent c'est le cas en
ce moment de culligan france dont le
siège est basé à voisins le bretonneux
elle met tout de suite je vous propose
de prendre la direction du centre de
recherche et de développement de merck
la boîte heure où le numérique fait
partie du quotidien des équipes que ce
soit dans les laboratoires ou bien dans
les outils de formation
reportage nous sommes à guyancourt c'est
ici qu est installée l'entreprise mère
clab water filiale du groupe merck fait
le lead
mondial des générateurs d'eau purifiée
pour les industries et les laboratoires
et super vieira né le numérique a pris
une place particulièrement importante
[Musique]
nicolas barré bonjour vous êtes manager
recherche développement ici amer que la
boîte heures première question est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter
brièvement les activités qui sont
pratiqués ici
alors en effet ici nous fabriquons des
systèmes de purification d'eau nous
concevons plus particulièrement des
systèmes de purification d'eau pour des
applications pharmaceutiques ou le
contrôle qualité dans le domaine
agroalimentaire ou
de la cosmétique par exemple alors le
numérique a évidemment fait partie de
notre quotidien depuis un an plusieurs
années le numérique il fait partie aussi
j'ai envie de dire du quotidien des
équipes de mer que la boîte heures
puisqu'il a été intégré il ya quelques
années on sait bien ça complètement et
intégralement le système que vous voyez
ici sont connectés pour les premières
générations au web depuis à peu près une
dizaine d'années ce sont des systèmes
qui maintenant ali la partie
connectivité sans fil tout ce qui est
voyant laisse le wifi le bluetooth la
rfid pour la traçabilité par exemple des
consommables
[Musique]
l'année 2010 est c'était une année très
important dans l'intégration de nouveaux
outils pour développer justement notre
activité de formation
donc on a changé notre lms learning
management system
donc notre plateforme de gestion des
informations
les axes de modernisation c'est plutôt
la l'apprentissage par le jeu qui
lorsqu'on appelle gentside learning
l'apprentissage pas les vidéos aux modes
et les séries télé série parce que quand
comme jeudi deux hommes au nez de la
génération youtube
on va mettre à disposition des playlists
et vidéo où les personnes peuvent
chercher les sujets qui les intéressent
pour apprendre les choses et dernières
mois mais le plus intéressant pour moi
c'est plutôt la réalité augmentée où on
va être dans ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage immersif c'est à dire on
est dans la simulation comme si c'est la
vraie vie
je
le numérique qui s'apprivoise dès le
plus jeune âge
exemple à elancourt ou 300 élèves test
depuis un mois le projet bouge ta classe
à leur disposition de nouveaux espaces
pédagogiques comme vous allez le
découvrir dans ce sujet de wilfrid richy
et de patrick jacq dixmude repenser
réaménager ses salles de classe de
l'école élémentaire de la commanderie à
elancourt doivent permettre de faciliter
les enseignements ne cherchez plus les
bancs ni l'estrade et son tableau ici
l'on peut s'asseoir confortablement et
l'on peut même circulé pendant les cours
un enfant de 10 ans n'est pas fait pour
rester pendant six heures assis devant
une table
il a besoin de bouger il ya des postures
et donc ça ça lui permet de changer de
posture et de mieux se concentrer
1 et 2 de prendre l'acte d'apprendre
comme du plaisir donc c'est important
il a plusieurs sites qui peut changer
ils changent exercice et c'est ce qui
renouvelle ses stimuli et qui augmente
sa concentration et donc sa mémorisation
et donc ses résultats scolaires
les évolutions ne s'arrête pas là
puisque les usages des tablettes des
robots ou de la visioconférence donne
lieu à un avant goût de l'école du futur
ces classes repenser sont le résultat
d'un travail mené depuis dix ans avec
les outils numériques on est obligé
d'apprendre autrement avec une autre
posture
donc on a fait un concours par les
enseignants en leur demandant d'imaginer
leur classe autrement avec les outils
numériques
ce qu'ils ont fait la société manutan
s'est ensuite chargé de concrétiser les
idées pour les résultats les enseignants
notent déjà un encadrement simplifiée
des élèves en difficulté et une plus
grande autonomie des plus aguerris
ce qui devrait permettre de généraliser
ces changements aux autres écoles de la
ville et dans les autres communes une
tentative supplémentaire de remonter au
classement pisa qui évalue les
performances des systèmes scolaires dans
le monde
la finlande figure de modèle en matière
de nouvelles classes y pointe au 5e rang
la france est actuellement 25e des
innovations pédagogiques que l'on
retrouve également dans l'enseignement
supérieur l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines situe à
guyancourt abrite par exemple un mur
immersive pour la recherche et
l'enseignement reportage mieux
visualiser le champ magnétique de la
terre avec des lunettes de réalité
virtuelle et huit écrans géants full hd
un exercice rendu possible avec la
plateforme here depuis quatre ans
l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines située à
guyancourt abrite ce mur immersive pour
la recherche et l'enseignement
il est destiné aussi bien aux chercheurs
ingénieurs ou encore aux étudiants est
aujourd'hui c'est plus une séance de
travail sur le thème de l'ingénierie
concourantes donc l'ingénierie
concourantes c'est du travail
collaboratif là par exemple ces
c'est une séance de travail sur le
dimensionnement de cubes soit le capsat
sont de petits satellites qu'on envoie
dans l'espace de l'ordre de la dizaine
de kg une surface de 6 mètre par un
mètre 70 16 millions de pixels
il est désormais plus simple de faire de
la modélisation 3d
en fait c'est beaucoup plus pratique à
utiliser un ordinateur directement parce
que là c'est plus éloignées donc ça
abîme - les yeux je dirais et puis on
peut voir beaucoup plus de choses on
peut utiliser excel et en même temps
voir ce qui se passe sur sur le rendu 3d
de cette élite model concrets font la
taille les personnes qui sont dans la
salle et le mur qui est aussi immersif
en 3d nous permet de visualiser en fait
les objets techniques concrets de façon
très immersive on peut quasiment rentré
dedans comme si on était dangereux
jeux d'enfants c'est beaucoup plus
intuitif pour avancer sur des projets
complexes parfois en terme
technique ou de sciences pour les
collègues qui sont sur zone intégré au
sein de la plate forme d'intégration et
de test de l'eau vs q ce mur d'image xxl
est également à disposition des
entreprises et plusieurs projets
pédagogiques en lien avec le numérique
sont développées au sein de l'ue vs q le
15 juin dernier lors d'une journée
consacrée à ce thème nous avons
rencontré patricia ou non vice-président
de lever est ce qu en charge du
numérique
patricia gonon bon soir bonsoir vous
êtes vice présidente déléguée en charge
du numérique et de la transformation
pédagogique a lu vs qq alors c'est un
domaine qui a été renforcée il ya
quelques mois je crois qu'elles sont
précisément vos missions oui alors c'est
un effectivement j'ai été élu par le
conseil d'administration sur proposition
du prix proposition du président en
février 2018
l'idée de renforcer la stratégie la mise
en oeuvre de la stratégie du numérique
des transformations pédagogique qui est
une des stratégies forte de la
présidence du président alain buis donc
mes missions ça va consister à mettre en
oeuvre la stratégie du numérique la
transformation pédagogique pour impulser
une dynamique autour de ces dossiers
thématiques là donc ça veut dire
proposer une politique incitative auprès
des enseignants de l'université pour
mettre en oeuvre des projets
pédagogiques repenser les espaces les
lieux d'apprentissage de favoriser les
usages la formation aux usages du
numérique et bien d'autres alors
pourquoi le numérique finalement est
devenue maintenant incontournable j'ai
envie de dire dans la pédagogie alors le
numérique est déjà très présent il est
déjà utilisé depuis de plusieurs années
dans la pédagogie mais c'est vrai que
l'évolution du numérique fait que le
numérique et dans nos vies au quotidien
les étudiants utilisent beaucoup aussi
du numérique les smartphones
et c est le numérique est intéressant
parce qu'il permet du coup de deux de
favoriser des nouveaux lieux
d'apprentissage de s'approprier de
mettre en place des nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques de séquences et des temps
d'apprentissage pouvoir aussi permettre
à toute personne qu'il soit distance ou
pas n'importe quel lieu de pouvoir
consulter des ressources pédagogiques de
pouvoir apprendre des choses est de
pouvoir proposer quelque chose pour tous
les publics et de manière adaptée
qu'est-ce qui a concrètement donc déjà
été mis en place ici a lu vs qu alors
concrètement on a répondu aussi dans ma
mission on a répondu à beaucoup beaucoup
d'appels à projets aussi sur des projets
pédagogiques porté par des enseignants
donc là pour l'instant on a par exemple
beaucoup de projets qui sont en cours
notamment on a un projet sur les
urgences périnatale qui est porté par
anne rousseau qui est enseignante sage
femme a dû faire de santé simone veil et
avec qui je participe à ce projet l'idée
de ce projet c'est de proposer une offre
de formation sur les urgences périnatale
et plus particulièrement sur deux
compétences que son l'hémorragie du post
partum et la résignation réanimation du
nouveau né
ainsi on propose différents modules de
formation d'autoformation des exercices
applicatifs et aussi des formations en
présentiel via un centre de simulation
où on a des mannequins en se met en
pratique dans le centre de simulation
qui a été inauguré et deux ans au niveau
de l'université est ainsi ce parcours là
peut être proposés aussi bien en
formation initiale qu'en formation
continue c'est à dire à des
professionnels de santé des sages femmes
ou bien aussi à des étudiants
sages-femmes et étudiants en santé
là on a été retenu pour un projet de
salle de formation de l'université
ile-de-france dans que ce projet de
centre de formation sera installé au
coeur de la bibliothèque universitaire
de saint quentin en yvelines dans un
espace en verre et qui permettra en fait
d'avoir dû mobilier modulable qui
permettra d'avoir des situations
d'apprentissage varié avec du numérique
aussi pour te faire du travail on petit
groupe en plus grands groupes et
permettant de mettre en place des
pédagogies dite active du travail en
groupe exr
une dernière question par rapport à
toute cette cette innovation pédagogique
comment se situe du vs cube par rapport
aux autres universités françaises est ce
que lui vs puis est en avance on peut
dire qu est ce qu est en avance dans la
moyenne nationale
on va dire que lui vs qu il ya de très
beaux projets il ya un dynamisme très
importante qui a été qui est qui est
réel là depuis depuis depuis un an et
demi même avant il y avait déjà et non
du vécu et est quand même assez bien
positionné il ya aussi bien d'aider des
projets en recherche la recherche de
qualité très variés on est une
université pluridisciplinaire donc du
coup c'est ça permet d'avoir des choses
très riche et le dynamisme et beaucoup
de projets en cours et là on sent qu'il
ya beaucoup de deux choses encore à
amener certes mais il ya un réel
dynamisme louis merci patricia gounon je
rappelle que vous êtes vice présidente
déléguée en charge du numérique de la
transformation pédagogique a lu vs qu à
présent si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi apprenez de quoi noter
l'entreprise culligan france dont le
siège est basé à voisins le bretonneux
propose plusieurs offres dans les
yvelines
bonjour je suis julie rosinha perrin je
suis directrice marketing et
communication de culligan france alors
qu lagan france a lancé en 2018 une
grande campagne de recrutement nous
recrutons 400 nouveaux collaborateurs
cette année et dans les yvelines nous
avons deux agences une à plaisir une
épaule et puis également notre siège
social ici à voisins le bretonneux
actuellement nous recrutons un
technicien pour notre agence d'epône et
deux nouveaux collaborateurs pour
l'équipe marketing un chef de produit et
un stagiaire ou en alternance et dès la
fin du mois d'août nous lancerons une
nouvelle grande campagne de recrutement
là essentiellement pour des conseillers
commerciaux
nous recruterons plus de cinq
conseillers commerciaux dans les
yvelines
donc rendez vous sur culligan recrute
point fr pour pouvoir découvrir tous ces
nouveaux postes à pourvoir dans
l'entreprise c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi à très
bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]